This conic section would just be a circle. Great work if you chose that one.
Just like before, we want to get the X squared term on the same side as the y
squared term. So we can add x squared to both sides of the equation to get this
equation. Now, you might not be used to seeing, the y squared term come first,
and in fact, we can reverse the order of addition since it's commutative. Two
plus one would be the same thing as one plus two. So y squared plus x squared
is the same as x squared plus y squared. And just to be sure, I'll show you
each of these equations graphed, so we see that they represent the same exact
circle. This is the first one, this is the second one, and this is the third
one. All three circles are exactly the same.